if we could find a way of capturing  storing and Tran and and and  distributing energy from renewable  resources we could undercut the the cost  of digging for coal and oil and because  we could make it cheaper that source of  pollution would disappear within decades  and we would solve our problems so what  we need is a universal plan where the  scientific brains of the world get  together and work out a roadmap to solve  where the jams are whether the  difficulties are and to do it within the  next ten years if you could put a man on  the moon in 10 years we can surely do  that and if we did that the source of  global warming would disappear it is  never in the history of the world in the  case that human beings of all kinds have  got together and agreed on something  happens about and so certainly that it's  going to be hugely difficult to get  agreement but if we don't we are in for  disaster